[Music]
do
hello
scott am i on i'm on all right
welcome
hello to everybody in here and making
their way in here
and hello to everybody online
you are here tonight it is seems like a
good night to be together to remember
that you're not alone to remember that
you were surrounded by love and by
community
surrounded by god's presence
um
before we get started into worship i
want to just acknowledge a couple of
things that
most of you
are most likely aware of um
the war
in ukraine
is one of them um
just
really hard to watch and um
hard to think of people in the midst of
of that right now
um and the wars that have been going on
for
a while
um
secondly
uh
just the recent
anti-trans anti-gay bills that are
trying to be pushed through
in this state specifically as well as
other states
um our governor at the helm and
i've just been really really sad and
angry
at this stuff
and
i don't feel like i'm qualified to stand
up here and say anything about it other
than
as a christian as a follower of jesus
i'm really angry and sad
about all of it and if you're not aware
of
the stuff that governor abbott his
letter based on
attorney general paxton's opinion legal
opinion
look it up
look it up it is worth your time to
educate yourself to educate ourselves on
what is going on and to be able to do
the things we can do
i will say that at the table we stand
unequivocally
with our trans siblings especially our
kids especially our kids and their
parents that are trying to
love them the best they can and provide
good care and the doctors and mental
health specialists that are providing
care
and
yeah my heart is just heavy my heart is
heavy and
so i just thought we could take some
time
just in silence and in prayer
just to offer up your own words to god
about these things
offer up your sadness your anger
feelings are not off the table when it
comes to god
god is ready to meet you right where you
are
and church is the place where you can
bring that we don't check it at the door
we're honest about how we're feeling
we're honest about what's going on in
the world
with stuff like this i i feel like
silence is not an option
these are the times where it's important
to stand up and say especially to the
vulnerable especially to the
marginalized that we are with you
and we're not going to stand for hate
we're not going to stand for political
posturing
we're not going to stand for people
being called issues
or being called less than
being made in the image of god
so let's take this to god
god
um
yeah we offer up
sadness confusion
anger
just everything that we're feeling right
now
and we ask for you as the source of love
the source of hope
the source of peace
god be our center
jesus be our center
right now
as we feel like we have the weight of
the world on our shoulders
carrying burdens
carrying people on our minds and our
hearts
god we surrender
all of that to you right now
and god we remember that we're not alone
we ask for your peace over our world
ask for
your wisdom and guidance for our leaders
worldwide and locally
and god right now
just envision
all of us linking arms together
standing on your truth your hope and
your love
and god may your spirit fill us may your
spirit cover the world
on earth as it is in heaven
so god we give you tonight
god i'm thankful for the hope that you
provide
where we run low or run dry god help us
to always run to you
to remember that we're surrounded by
your love you're the source of the love
and god you were still orchestrating and
working things for good even in the
darkest moments
in jesus name amen
thanks karen
i so appreciate karen's um for one
her willingness to share her resources
and
um
her connection to information that goes
on because i can be so uh
you know the here and now like what's
right in front of me and i feel like
karen has this gift to see beyond what's
happening right in front of us and
what's going on around us and in the
rest of the world and i need friends
like her who will be like hey did you
hear about that bill and i'm like
excuse me what like
so i just appreciate that karen thank
you for always drawing our eyes out to
what's going on um beyond
our sphere
and we've had a lot going on in our
sphere this week it has been quite a
comedy of errors
and uh our good friend brian
has been over to our house a million
times it feels like because we keep
having plumbing issues just coming out
of our
well toilets and walls
and slabs and front yards it's just been
so ridiculous you guys
um
and so anyways i'm grateful for a space
tonight where we can
engage something um
that's like just like what karen was
doing drawing our eyes up drawing our
eyes to god and what he's doing among us
so will you guys join us stand up
with us as we enter this worship time
together we are all equal members and
participants here so please sing along
with us um as we get started
one two three four one two three four
[Music]
is
[Applause]
[Music]
it's is around us
can take us
[Music]
you have redeemed us
your love has found us it's all around
[Music]
the darkest nights will
set us free
[Music]
yours forever
forever
[Music]
set us free
we will see
because your love has found us even
[Music]
set us free
just the voices we will see
because your love has found
the darkest nights will sing
because
your love has set us free
[Music]
yes god
thank you so much for your freedom thank
you for finding us
in our dark places god
in our mountains and our valleys you are
there through all of it with us walking
each step
god and we want to meet you where we are
[Music]
i lose my ability
to be afraid when i
see the way
you
love me
[Music]
and all the fear that held my
feet to the floor
you don't hold me anymore
when i
see your face
everything changes in the
[Music]
shadows that hang around
lord i fall
down again
i'm finding out
just who
i
am
[Music]
fill my head
everything changes
[Music]
chasing away those
i'm finding out just who
i
[Music]
am out just who
i
am
[Music]
hopelessness and pain
goodbye
[Music]
is
waited for this moment
[Music]
everything changes the
radiance of your smile
[Music]
you got this away
chasing away though
[Music]
everything changes
i'm finding out
[Music]
waited for this moment
for all my days
[Music]
would you guys join with me in the
prayer of the people and if you're
online joining us feel free to leave a
comment
in the comment sections whenever we get
to the point where we're lifting up
names and situations
read this along with me
for the city of saxi texas and for every
city and community and all of those who
live in them
we pray to you
for the good earth that you have given
us and the wisdom and the will to
conserve it
we pray to you
for those who travel on land sea or air
for the old and the sick
for the widow and the orphan
for the injured and the suffering we
pray to you
for the poor and the oppressed the
unemployed and destitute
for prisoners and captives and for all
who remember and care for them
we pray to you lord we know that you
love us and that you hear us
and so we lift these names and
situations up to you
harper
[Music]
hathaway
nikki
andreessen's
for the names and the moments that we've
spoken aloud and for those that we have
kept in our hearts
we pray to you that they may have life
and light
healing and hope
peace and a deep sense of your presence
amen
[Music]
i
broken within
overwhelmed by the weight of your sin
jesus is
[Music]
jesus is calling
the precious
[Music]
leave behind your regrets and mistakes
come today there's no
[Music]
from the ashes a new life is born
jesus
[Music]
the precious blood
forgiveness
[Music]
so what a savior
doesn't he
want therefore
[Music]
christ is
hallelujah
[Music]
the precious blood of jesus christ
very across as you wait for the crown
[Music]
scott thank you for being our savior
for being over all things
here in front of us and around the world
[Music]
god we come to you
knowing that you invite us in
that you make space and room for us
that each one of us is your child
each one of us is loved and seen
and known
[Music]
would we learn to see others the way
that you have seen us
would we learn to offer love
the way that you have offered it to us
teach us to forgive
teach us to bless
teach us to heal
and to mend
where there's a need for it
[Music]
help us to be jesus to this world
it's in your name i pray
amen
if you guys want to go ahead and sit
down and turn to the people around you
and say hello brett will get started
with our message
well good evening everyone
grace and peace
everyone doing okay
yeah
yeah all right cool cool
cool
well um
it's really really good to be with all
of you and uh that of course includes us
joining us online
love you lots as always we are
one church in many places so
um also anyone who is kind of new or
just you know getting settled in making
their way into the community i um
want to name that you can um you can be
yourself
you know sometimes people come into a i
don't know a religious space you know
and feel like kind of i gotta pretend
i've gotta
you know um
and i just wanna i just wanna speak that
freedom over you that you can just be
yourself you know it could be your
personality just how god made you and um
you're that's like yeah wanted and
welcome so
um yeah so thank you for being here um
so we are in the midst of a series and
this is actually the uh the last message
in um at least part two of first peter
some point we'll get to part three
but you know there's five chapters and
so we're only now into chapter three so
still making our way through
um
but we are going to be hitting the pause
button after tonight because it'll be
the uh the season of lent and uh so
we'll go into that and then i don't know
maybe we'll wait a little while maybe
maybe it'll be spring maybe we'll wait
till summer i don't know we'll return to
peter at some point um i think some of
you seem very antsy like keep it going
and then others are kind of like i don't
know i could just get the read you know
it's kind of like oh that's that's good
that's enough of first beer i think we
got pretty much the hang of it you know
and
even the laughter oh that communicates
something it'll probably be the summer
that's the uh it'll probably it'll
probably take some time
um
so uh
so tonight is um
yeah we'll be kind of kind of wrapping
up and um
the i'm gonna start here there's a uh a
wonderful i love this metaphor it was
the writer rob bell he gives in his uh
book velvet elvis
um an excellent excellent book
and he gives a metaphor
of the the christian faith he says
christian faith it's like it's like a
trampoline
and
the various uh like doctrines theologies
you know stories of the of the christian
faith and such uh he says those are like
like the springs
you know kind of around the edge of the
trampoline like um
in essence they're they're very
important you know i mean there's like
no springs no trampoline you know so
they're super important however
he points out that the uh
you know the point of a trampoline is
not the springs
right like if someone had you over like
dude check out my new trampoline like
look at these springs you know look
they're so they're so coiled i don't
know what you'd say about springs um you
know you'd be kind of like oh that's
cool especially if you're a little kid
maybe as adults you're kind of like yeah
i'm happy to just look at the springs i
don't really want to get on that thing
but let's say if you're a kid you know
when i brush it like look at this new
trampoline you know and look at these
springs you wouldn't believe look at
them they're so aren't they unique you
know they're like because what does a
little kid want to do they want to get
on that trampoline and freaking jump
right like because that's the point of
the trampoline right is that it's
jumping
jumping on the trampoline and he um
says in a similar way the point of the
christian life
is um while it's important the doctrines
the stories the theology the springs in
essence are super important without them
you know no christian faith like it's
you know it's important but at the end
of the day the point isn't just to
endlessly pontificate
you know kind of pull the stories apart
and
you know at the end of the day the point
of the springs is of the christian faith
is to encourage the jumping in other
words the living
you know what i mean like
that's the point of the christian faith
learn to jump learn to live
uh
and in essence you could be an expert in
the springs
right like oh i know all of the
doctrines of the christian faith i've
got i know all the stories you know like
and yet you could
while it would help it might
encourage you right the having some
knowledge can really help you understand
faith and then but at the end of the day
i mean is the book of james right like
faith without works without action
without the living the jumping uh just
we're just losing the point we're just
losing the plot you know it's like
that's the point so um the reason i name
this is because we come to a topic
tonight
that it is um
just incredibly practical it is like it
is just about the jumping the living of
uh of christian faith so the title of
the message is revenge or blessing
revenge or blessing
and um it's another timely one god keeps
doing this to us i wrote this message
two weeks ago um
so just you know god keeps god he knows
what he's up to he's he's helping guide
me as much as i know son doesn't miss it
but i think sometimes i'm i'm hearing
him
so um so i want to start uh well
actually before we read i wanna i'm
gonna name
so tonight there's um
the passage we'll be getting into uh
first peter 3 verses 9 through 14. um
it's it gets that some it's really
naming a practice again because it's
about the jumping the living a practice
that is referenced a number of different
times in the scriptures slightly
different language
um
you
in the book of matthew chapter 5 jesus
calls it turning the other cheek
also calls it loving your enemy
first peter peter here will call he'll
use the language of not returning evil
for evil or insult for insult
but evil with a blessing um romans 12
paul uses much the same language as both
peter and jesus partly because paul and
peter are of course just kind of taking
jesus words and then you know applying
them in their own context so it's the
same thing um
peter actually quotes in this passage he
quotes the psalms you'll notice a little
apostrophe at a point a single one and
that's he starts quoting the psalms
before he comes back to his own language
so there's there's references this in
the old testament isn't just like the
new testament you know um
this is all over the bible um
so it's it's referenced in various ways
some of the it's that some of that's
that's the biblical language i just gave
you it's also called kind of you know
philosophers theologians people
reflecting on this language and on these
kind of various scriptures they'll use
the language of non-violence
some people call it pacifism
others non-retaliation others
peacemaking now all those words kind of
have their own shades of meaning you
know in a kind of applied in different
contexts you know when you think of
pacifism you think of like war you know
or something so it's it's sort of all
they got their own angle and yet at the
end of the day a lot of them are kind of
hearkening back to this biblical
language and they're it's like the this
this is the practice this is the the
thing um that they're all kind of
getting at so with that in mind let's go
ahead and read it first peter 3 um
verses 9 through 14.
he says do not repay evil with evil or
insult with insult
on the contrary repay
evil with blessing
because to this you were called so that
you will so that you may inherit a
blessing
for you see now it's the quote it's the
psalm for whoever would love life and
see good days must keep their tongue
from evil in their lips from deceitful
speech they must turn from evil and do
good they must seek peace and pursue it
for the eyes of the lord or on the
righteous and his ears are attentive to
their prayer but the face of the lord is
against those who do
evil
now this is back to him he's no longer
quoting
he says who's going to harm you if
you're eager to do good
and then he goes into verse 14 almost as
though he kind of realizes well actually
that can happen so then he continues but
but uh
even if you should suffer for what is
right
you are blessed
you are blessed do not fear their
threats do not be
frightened
so here um basically you probably get it
right like
peter's basically saying um
when uh someone insults you um when they
put you down when they they try to hurt
you um
especially you know if they try to hurt
you even with their words um basically
don't respond in the same way
right he says respond um with with a
blessing
um
now notice he goes he's going even a
little further than some of us might say
like well um like i remember uh growing
up i'd hear from my mother and others
you know if you don't have something
nice to say
what
don't say anything at all you all know
your mom said that too
um yeah you notice um and that's a good
principle i've said it to my kids we all
have these moments where we're like oh
yeah i am my parent here i go um
and i just use this and it's a good line
it's a good you know you can see it's
sort of a stepping stone right you start
with
because someone says something they do
something that you know i mean and you
have that immediate y'all know the
reaction
though we're gonna close at the end with
a few stories and i think you'll
resonate with some of these because it's
that moment you know where it just hits
you and it's like before you even know
what you're doing like they yell at you
and you're just like what was that you
know i mean like and it's only like i
don't know
sometimes five minutes sometimes five
hours later you've kind of calmed down
you're like oh yeah that wasn't
that wasn't the best you know
because it's what we do right so that's
actually a really good stepping stone is
when someone insults when someone hurts
when someone does it you just
zip right that's probably not going to
be your wisest moment you know your
wisest words would probably not be
spoken right then
um so that's something but notice
peter's going beyond that
right it's not he doesn't just say don't
you know when they do that don't don't
say a word don't even dignify them with
a response that's what he said he
actually says in that very moment
respond with a word of
blessing
um
now just to what i want to do is i want
to remind us just how deep in the
christian story this goes because i
think it's easy to kind of hear these
various passages i mean i could read the
passage from matthew 5 we could read the
whole psalm we could you know and be
like and i think intellectually we're
kind of like yeah yeah that's good
that's good that's good for other people
to do um
you know
this is sort of one of those principles
that we really wish everyone else would
do you know we're like yes
they need to do that
you know but when it's sort of like
no but my circumstance this is different
you know
um
and so what i want to do is get a little
bit beyond just the intellect or the you
know the like well there's a verse that
says such and such so do it you know
that's kind of like something you know
and yet it doesn't necessarily hit the
heart so i want to i want to just remind
us like how d because this goes deep in
the christian story
this goes deep into
christian history and christian memory
um remember the night
jesus was betrayed by judas
and remember the the soldiers
and the angry mob
kind of a mixture of like religious
leaders perhaps other politicians we
don't know some we know some of their
assistants are there partly because one
of them gets injured which we'll get to
in just a moment um
so this mob the soldiers they come to
arrest him
right um
the disciple a lot of the disciples
start to flee not peter
right um
and so they come and
then what is peter one of the the key
kind of jesus friends jesus one of the
disciples the twelve what is remember
what he does
grabs out that sword he's got a sword
and he starts
swinging
and uh apparently he wasn't very good
somewhat embarrassingly he's trying to
kill a man he just he misses
um but he gets the guy's ear
gets his which tells you how close
i mean mike that was about to get real
violent you know i mean so he swings
not very good probably more of a
fisherman you know he swings he misses
cuts the man's ear off remember what
jesus does well first what does he say
to peter
peter put away your sword
that's what he says
and then he picks up the man's ear
and heals him
i mean think about this is a man who was
part of the mob coming to arrest him
and he heals the man
then um they arrest him hours later
uh
the next day he's now hanging on the
cross
and it's it's his oppressors there right
it's it's humanity
um
it's us
right that's actually part of the
tradition if you're here on a good
friday the day where we remember the
crucifixion of jesus a lot of traditions
will have a moment where you shout
crucify him
you shall and that's like part of the
christian
liturgy isn't like you know to read
aloud and then they those bad people
what you'll never believe what they did
actually in the tradition what do you
what do we have to do we all have to
shout out
crucify
can you see what the what it's trying to
get at
right it's not some distance it's not
like those evil people over there it's
it's us right so he's there
looking down at humanity at us
and do you remember what he said what
does he not say he doesn't say
father let them have it
what is he what does he say father
forgive them
for they do not know what they are doing
in that moment when jesus is
being all the things peter's talking
about
reviled
insulted
persecuted
in that very moment he
he speaks
a prayer
and he speaks words of
blessing over them
like can you see how this isn't just
about like a few random verses you know
a few proof texts oh i found a verse
that says this you know you can find a
verse that defends almost anything in
the bible this is this this one go it
goes right right to the heart can you
see why i said the very beginning this
goes right to the heart of the of the
jumping of the living of christian faith
right because why because it goes so
deep in the story
so so deep in
the story um you know we often talk
about um taking up our own cross
jesus said you know if anyone wants to
come after me they must take up their
cross and follow me
and uh and so christians you know we'll
kind of interpret that usually as
suffering in some way and we'll say like
um yeah okay i need to take up my cross
so um you know i've got this illness
and so like that's my cross to bear you
know or maybe someone has like a job
they don't like and they're like yep
that's hey we've all got our cross don't
we all got across the bear and that's my
cross got that job okay i like my job i
mean you guys you know
um
it's weird that pastor is like
complaining about his jaws weird
um
now i think that's a fine i'm not saying
like that's a bad interpreter like no i
get it right that's a good parallel to
kind of jesus life kind of connecting a
bridge to our life and you know um and
yet can you see that like in light of
that jesus story in light of these
passages like can you see to take up
your cross and follow him
can you see that that like that means
something specific
right that is that's about moving
through the world in a spirit in a in a
heart posture
um that that is not um full of
retaliation and vengeance and violence
in payback
because that's like the problem with the
world correct
everyone's playing that game
everyone
and yet to take up our cross and follow
him it means we
that well we can put it like this
it means when insulted
do not insult
when injured do not injured when spoken
ill of do not speak ill of others when
put down do not put others down
right and then not only that not only
the don't do the negative don't do the
thing you know but again and yeah and
also move beyond that and as god's grace
enables you
even begin to speak words of prayer and
blessing
over people and in that moment
you are you are just like jesus
in that moment
you're exactly in the posture of
of christ
another way i might sum it up is this
christians are people
who seek the good who speak the blessing
who say the prayer who bring the peace
this is who we are
we seek the good we speak the blessing
we say the prayer we bring the peace
now um at this point
you know people have uh
they have questions
you know lots of questions i would have
quite at least if i were you i would
have questions you know um usually the
questions
are are kind of about how does this um
there's a few ways to think of it um how
does this scale up is some of the
language i've heard people use like how
does this scale up how does this scale
out
um by scale up they mean like how does
this apply um at the level of like
nation states and governments and
i mean if you're getting on this whole
non-retaliation train well like how far
does how high does that go and honestly
um the answer to that is um it's
complicated and christians argue about
it a lot you know like what does that
mean uh how do we i mean and for example
like if um even it's not even just like
war you know but it's it's even
something as um
more kind of day in day out at even
local level as like policing
you know and like if someone um
you know if you if you arrest someone
and then put them in jail you could kind
of argue like well it's not you're not
saying like well blessings go upon your
way you know like you're kind of using
force
to you know and so this is where peop
christians argue and kind of wrestle
with like oh how does this
how do we scale up you know
um the scale out question is how does
this work like um interpersonally but
like in extreme
circumstances um you know i mean the
classic example is like are you saying
like what if someone breaks into my
house and they're like i'm gonna hurt
your child
you know
what then pastor brett like are you
literally saying like well again
blessings
go and pit you know i
i guess you know i hope you don't come
in but if you do i have nothing but
prayers for you you know like this just
seems like the stupidest
like
what
um
like what do you do you know what do you
do with that i think that what we're
what we're kind of bumping up against at
the edges and again this gets really
complicated kind of theologically where
people go with this and um
you know how does it apply and such um
but
i'll i'll just name that i think some of
where um
where we start to wrestle with in our
day-to-day lives is like what's the
edges of this and where does it maybe
like not work or not apply or not like
we've bumped up against the edges is in
that moment
when um
doing nothing would actually perpetuate
violence itself
making us in essence sort of not just
like kind of bystanders but actually in
some sense participants to the injustice
and the violence right that's why there
is something sort of sick about a parent
standing by
as something's happening their kid you
know i mean it's just weird and like no
you gotta just
you gotta put your hands on them
you know i mean right um now now here's
the thing
um
and i think it's similar at the scale-up
level by the way
you know what do you mean ukraine russia
right now like a lot of christians in
ukraine they're just like hey come on in
come on in blessings upon you you know
like they're
you know
um
now here's the thing
here's the thing
um most uh
i'll say it like this
um i think we can get derailed by those
edges and extremes and in fact use those
edges and extremes to sort of avoid our
actual
life
right again coming back to the jumping
metaphor like 99
of our jumping and our living are not
the like extremes and as a pastor i have
to work with folks in the extremes you
know like what about incredible like
extreme you know abuse for years or you
know what you're saying like well you
need to say you know say forgive you
right now like of course it gets sort of
silly and you know like okay
um
in other words we there's no limits on
forgiveness and blessing we have the
ideal we're longing for it we're praying
for it we're working through it
or towards it
um
and yet we also have to acknowledge that
our life often is not actually at the
extremes
and most of our living is like it's all
of the petty
crap we're dealing with every day
like the and that's where i think we
could have all sorts of debates and oh
i'm open to all emails whatever you want
to email me coming from i'm open and
i'll have those conversations but we
could get really lost in all of that at
the end of the day like 99 of our living
is so much more petty and
practical in like down to earth
than the edges are you are you following
with me
um and what we don't want to do is use
the edges as an excuse
to then say ah see this doesn't work in
the real world
and so i just will go on about living my
life the way i want
you know
um
there's a writer who i quote often
richard beck he has a great line about
this he asked um someone was talking to
him about like what's your what's the
point of all of your he's a christian
and uh he's like what's the point of all
your christian practices all you mean
because he's involved in a lot he
teaches at a christian um
uh university he's uh he teaches sunday
school he helps out at a local prison um
teaching bible study he um does a lot of
you know praying and worshiping just as
an individual christian and you know all
the things and they're like what's the
point like what are you getting at man
with all of that like are you hoping for
like big things like union with god you
know or something he's like well that
would be nice but honestly he said i
love this he said uh truth be told i'm
just trying by god's grace to be a
little bit less of a jerk today than it
was yesterday
i love that answer
love it
because i i think that's where this
verse actually touches down our lives
like that's the key
how can i be less of a jerk today than i
was yesterday how can we as a community
be less jerkish
one year from now
than we are this moment just before lent
2022 right like that's that's the
journey and that's where so much of our
life is actually happening
it's in all that's in the 10 000 little
interactions and that's where this verse
it touches down so
powerfully in our lives
because he's just naming when people
hurt you when they insult when they put
you down when they belittle with like in
those moments like don't respond in kind
like learn to be like christ
respond not with words of hatred and
vengeance and but respond with a
blessing in other words um this is about
that moment
when your kid for those who have kids
they're looking at you
and they are screaming you never thought
your kid would do this but here they are
they're screaming
i hate you
i mean it's loud you'd be surprised how
how much they can yell
i hate you you're the worst parent i'm
trying to kind of i don't want to be too
loud i want them to hear me you know um
i hate you you're the worst you're the
worst parent you're the stupidest idiot
like they're just they're caught they're
all in their feelings and it's just it's
happening it's on you know just the
worst bird i hate you you're an idiot
i'm just losing now in that moment
here's the question
will you go to war
like that's
that's the question first people like in
that moment it's first peter 3 9 like
will you go to war or or will you say
like
okay dear jesus
look
you are not at your best right now
and i'm not at my best right now
and so we're gonna take 15 minutes
because i love you
i think i'm pretty sure i'm almost
certain no you don't say that don't
that's not like just say i i'm
i'm speaking it as though it is so i'm
speaking what i will live into i love
you and i'm for you and we're better
than this and so we're gonna try again
in 15 minutes or an hour if we need it
right um or a day
what is that
do not repay evil with evil
do not repay insult with insult on the
contrary repay evil with
blessing
it's that moment when you um post
something online
and uh the
people the trolls the whatever you want
to call them they come after you and
it's not like an intellectual
conversation you know i mean like oh
that's interesting points but i disagree
that's what i'm talking about i'm
talking about like the it's like you
post something and it's like personal
it's personal attacks and it's just you
know
whoa
my gosh they are coming after you i mean
we uh have this all the time you know
being
a a in a very small way somewhat of
public you know person posting things
and such and uh oh my gosh i remember um
anytime we run an ad or anything for the
table you know people will kind of click
over and read about our church and
they'll come back to the ad and they
have opinions you know opinions and um
usually they're not like done in a
gentle way like hey we disagree you know
it's sort of like it's mostly just bible
verses just post post post post post you
know quote
and in that mo i mean yo y'all you'll
think briar no you're so kind and loving
you know i mean a thing just rises up in
me like you think i'm an idiot you think
i don't know that you know i mean and
just oh my god it just jumps oh all over
you know what i mean like we in our
mission statement we say
our our mission is to shift a generation
from reactionary to visionary through
the personal work of jesus that's what
we're called to do that's the
reactionary moment
right just jumps all over you
and
um at my best
and my best literally these kinds of
passages i do actually come back to my
mind this is where i think it's in the
springs are important to know the
stories
you know and to know like okay okay
hey you know what we disagree and that's
okay but um
peace be with you
friend
blessings upon you
go with god
i'm for you you may not be for me
but i'm for you
you know
thanks brian
you know like that's the moment
you know it's about that moment when um
oh
that yes actually i have two friends um
right now and uh
they are they're they're dealing with it
they're in the school system lord bless
our teachers our principals our
administrators it's a it's hard y'all
some of you think you know but you don't
know like it's and it can be insane
there like the things they've been going
through um
and i
uh they so there's one kid in particular
right now
who i don't know what to call him he's
just she's troubled deeply deeply deeply
troubled
young kiddo elementary school um
but
they sent me pictures like this kid uh
uh not only like screams and yells that
would be like oh nothing you know this
is like the the kid punches them um
kicks
uh bites i got a text message from one
of my friends with a picture of the
marks of the teeth you know outlined on
the forearm um spits
in their faces
um picks up chairs throws the chairs
like i didn't get permission by the way
to show this um
throws the chairs look at this i mean
it's just
too much to
like and let me tell you in that moment
actually one of the one of the friends
he uh he hasn't just hasn't yet had the
official training there's like official
training for how you what you can do you
can't just go grab the kid like you're
out of control you know and wrestling
with the ground you can't do that
it doesn't matter if they're spitting on
you and throwing chairs at your face you
know so literally yet right now because
there's an official state way to
um i guess harness i don't know what the
word would be you know to get a kid in
control there's like a way you know but
he hasn't had the training yet so he can
only use barbie hands
barbie notes it's basically for those on
the podcast later it's the fingers you
know just locked you can't bend you
can't grab you know it's just he just
all he has really is like barbie hands
and a calming voice
and a long discipleship to jesus
and some i mean you think i'm joking but
like you know
y'all know the truth like that takes
tremendous emotional relational
spiritual maturity
to what
do not repay
evil for evil
insult for insult on the contrary repay
evil with a blessing
see this is our life
it's a it's a thousand and one sometimes
it's the extremes you know occasionally
but like mostly it's like
the ten thousand little moments
now i'll close with this you know you
may be thinking to yourself well yes
okay yes yes i agree i resonate like
this is true yes this would be better
the world would be better if i could do
this but here's the thing it would be
better for everyone else it would not be
better for me
you know what i mean like i'm just going
to suffer and this is just going to be
terrible for me so it's good for you
know the marriage and the kids and the
kids at school you know like whatever
but never not for me this is we've
actually been cutting you might have
caught this we've been cutting verse
nine short haven't we
this is the full verse nine he says do
not repay evil with evil or insult with
insult on the contrary repay evil with
blessing because to this you were called
so that you may inherit a blessing
that's an interesting closing line isn't
it
that you may inherit a blessing see
here's the truth
when we get in that moment
and we
it's payback time you know and hey maybe
rightly so like
justice is served you know like it had
it coming
you know
and yet when we do that
when we return the insult
we return the hurt
um
what happens is we just get caught up in
a in a cycle of hurt and pain
right because we kind of are hoping like
by hurting them
i'll be healed
you see it like by hurting them we'll
get i'll get them back and then i'll
feel better
um but actually what happens we just get
in a cycle and they hurt us and so we
hurt them and now we both feel crappier
and so then they return it and then we
volley it back it's like a game of sick
tennis you know just me here we go
and um
this is why well basically but when we
refuse retaliation when we speak the
blessing
what do we receive
we receive the blessing
we receive
the healing we start to receive the
wholeness
if you're taking notes you can write
this down revenge can never get you to
wholeness
only blessing and forgiveness can do
that
revenge can never get you to wholeness
only blessing and forgiveness can do
that
and is it a process sometimes
oh yeah
oh you better believe it like this isn't
about you know saying like so you know
go tonight and just forget real quick
you know like no sometimes sometimes
it's years sometimes a decade
more
but the point is
we're on the journey
so church by god's grace let's be the
peacemaking people
the blessing people the non-retaliation
people the people who are by god's grace
learning to be a little bit less of a
jerk
today
than we were yesterday
let me pray for you by your heads close
your eyes lord jesus
forgive
forgive us forgive our
moments of revenge our retaliation our
hurting of others god we want to let
those old ways go
we want we long to be a peace people
we long to be a healing people a
wholeness people
so empower us by your spirit
to speak words of blessing when we are
hurt to speak words of prayer and
comfort when reviled
help us to be a visionary people
in the name of the father
and the son and the holy spirit
amen
thanks brett um this last song we're
gonna close with it's straight out of
scripture and we did it a few weeks ago
um but if you weren't here
it's just
it's kind of this classic blessing
um
and
i just felt like
sometimes it's one thing for us to say
like yes i want to be that person that
speaks blessing over others but
sometimes we need practice
like what does that actually feel like
for those words to leave my mouth like
what would i actually say
this is just
an excellent prayer to be able to speak
over
um the people that we interact with the
people that are in our lives so if you
guys want to stand with us we're going
to close out with this blessing
let's practice
speaking his
love and truth over people
[Music]
lord bless you
and
keep you
make his face shine upon you
be gracious to you
lord turn his
[Music]
you face
lord bless you
[Music]
and keep you
make his face shine upon you
and be gracious to you
the lord turn
his face
you
and give you peace
then
[Music]
oh
may his favor
be upon you
and a thousand
generations
and your family
and your children and their children
and their children makes presence go
before you
and behind you and beside you all around
you and within you he is with you he is
with you every
[Music]
he is for you he is for you he is for
you
[Music]
amen
these presents go before you
and behind
and beside you
all around you and within you he is
[Music]
he is for you he is born
amen
[Music]
um
so
[Music]
somebody
thanks so much for being with us tonight
i hope this service
filled you in some way that was needed
and blessed you
a couple things before we go into the
benediction and dismissal
don't forget about the ash wednesday
service that's coming up this wednesday
march 2nd right here
7 pm we're going to join with pleasant
valley for a joint ash wednesday service
it'll be about 30 minutes long so please
be here for that
secondly
you guys want some good news for a
change
okay with cases coming down
and next sunday being the first sunday
in march
we're going to get back into our first
sunday rhythms
been waiting a while for this we're
going to have a communion together
during the service
and then after the service we're going
to go have dinner at pat creek and sexy
yeah so you're all invited
to that and i hope you'll be a part of
that as well
all right
i'd like to give you a blessing to take
with you into your week so if you'd like
to receive that blessing go ahead and
hold your hands out
i try to make eye contact with everybody
but i don't always get there so please
see me looking at you
you are a child of god
you
are a child of god
this is true on your best day
and it's true on your worst day
it's also true for everybody outside
these doors
so as you go into your week ahead
with its yet to be determined highs and
lows and everything in between
go with the assurance that you are loved
you are worthy
and you are accepted just as you are
and go filled with god's holy spirit
and the desire to extend these same
gifts
of love and grace to everybody you come
in contact with
be blessed
hope to see you back here on wednesday
and then again on sunday you are loved
[Music]
his
and presence
you